I'm Jen briny and I'm the host of the
congressional dispatch a stand I'm
filling in for David today while he
flies to Sin City in Las Vegas where
he's going to be reporting for you for
the rest of the week but I'm here today
in studio in Boston Massachusetts which
is a state that has recently legalized
marijuana and then I'm flying home
tomorrow to Oakland California where
we've had so-called legalize marijuana
for quite a while in full disclosure I
have a card I am experienced in the land
of legalized marijuana it's heaven it's
great to be able to walk in somewhere
and know exactly what you're getting
it's so much safer than meeting a guy
behind target to get god only knows what
it's a great system and I'm in full
support of it so just so you know where
I'm coming up from here but I'm also
here today in my role as Debbie Downer
to tell all of my stoner friends
nationwide that there actually is no
such thing in the United States as
legalized marijuana federally marijuana
is still a Schedule one drug which means
that it is as illegal as coke and heroin
and the federal penalties are just as
harsh as if you were caught with either
of those drugs but you probably have
noticed that I am here today as are all
of your stoner friends there has not
been some giant federal crackdown where
all of us are getting sent to prison
we're not seeing waves of stoners being
arrested all over the place we're seeing
that with immigration but we're not
seeing that with with marijuana at least
not yet
and the reason is that there has been a
provision for years that's been attached
to the Department of Justice section of
government funding that's been fought
for heart by members of both parties in
particular Republican Dana Rohrabacher
of California and Democrat Earl bloom an
hour of Oregon and here's what that
provision says it says none of the funds
made available under this Act to the
Department of Justice
justice may be used with respect to any
of the states of and then it lists 46
states and DC Guam and Puerto Rico to
quote prevent any of them from
implementing their own laws that or
authorize the use distribution
possession or cultivation of medical
marijuana now if you read that closely
you'll notice that that does not
legalize it it defied
enforcement and there is a huge
difference because in the Obama years
which is when all of the state-level
legalization happened you know the
Justice Department with his Attorney
General's in charge they didn't want to
crackdown on marijuana so this was
enough you know or at least it wasn't it
wasn't legalizing marijuana but we
weren't in any danger but now we're in
the era of Jeff Sessions and his
personal views on marijuana are fairly
well known this drug is dangerous you
cannot play with it it's not funny it's
not something to laugh about
and and trying to send that message with
clarity that good people don't smoke
marijuana and so with that in mind
here's what he said about enforcement of
federal marijuana laws during his
attorney general confirmation hearing in
January of 2017 one obvious concern is
that the United States Congress has made
the possession of marijuana in every
state and distribution of an an illegal
act so if you we need it if that
something is not desired any longer
Congress should pass a law to change
change the rule it's it's not so much
the Attorney General's job to decide
what laws are to enforce and Congress
has not changed that law what they've
done here is that they're preventing
Jeff Sessions or whoever is Attorney
General in the next six months you never
know when Trump's gonna go on another
firing spree but they've prevented the
Attorney General from using money to go
after medical marijuana users growers
and sellers only only medical marijuana
people and not in every state you know
this provision leaves out states and
territories from this enforcement
prohibition because in that that
provision that I read you there were
only 46 states concluded and they also
included DC Guam and Puerto Rico
excluded from that defunding of
enforcement are the Virgin Islands the
Northern Mariana Islands Kansas South
Dakota Nebraska and Idaho and so
marijuana possession use and sale in
those locations is federally well it's
federally illegal everywhere but they're
able to enforce those laws with
Department of Justice funds in those
locations in any way
they want to but in every state
regardless of state laws recreational
and other rights granted by the states
are still in first of all by the federal
government under Jeff Sessions and don't
take my word for it here's
representative jared Polis of legalized
marijuana state Colorado expressing his
concerns during the Rules Committee
hearing the only hearing that took place
about the Omnibus mr. chairman so states
like Colorado and many others have a
licensing system for medical marijuana
and also a licensing system for
recreational commercial marijuana that's
quick we also have the constitutional
right in our state for residents of our
state to have up to six plants that they
grow in their home for their own use
that's a constitutional right in our
state the voters put that in the
Constitution so those are not protected
by what is known as the Rohrbacher
blooming our language so it provides a
small degree of protection for some of
the the Medical dispensaries in our
state that's what I'm suggesting
most of our dispensaries offer the
commercially regulated marijuana and it
offers no protection for those who are
exercising their constitutional rights
in our state and again it is a
constitutional right in our state
constitution and so here's my point in
telling you this today we need to get
that law changed federally it's
important because we're now at the point
that 46 states are allowing you know
with their states rights or whatever
allowing us to use at least medical
marijuana and more and more every single
election are allowing recreational
marijuana but federally we can't allow
it to stay illegal now here's the good
news the good news is like I said before
this provision was fought very hard for
by representative Dana Rohrabacher of
California this guy is not a progressive
this guy thinks that global warming is
ridiculous but when it comes to
marijuana
he is conservative in the fact that he
believes the states rights and he is a
Republican who has made sure that this
was in the law that should give you hope
because there are Republicans who do
believe in states rights and they also
don't really want to have the backlash
from
all of the people in their states that
are using marijuana cuz there is a lot
of us and so this is something that even
though the Republicans are controlling
all three branches of Congress I
actually think that if we applied some
pressure we could get this law changed
and and also I mean Donald Trump has the
the pen he'd be the one signing it into
law but do you really think he's against
it you know I just don't and so right
now there's a lot of people who I think
want marijuana to be legalized and a lot
of people who think that it actually is
because we use that phrase but the truth
is that it isn't and until then we need
to pressure our people in Congress on
both sides of the aisle this is one
where if you live in a Republican state
it is worth pressuring your Republican
member of Congress I think they're open
to it and we need to be careful you know
I I know a lot of us like to fly with
our edibles and the thing is that that
is the TSA that's a federal agency when
you go through those security lines and
that is federal jurisdiction that's
where you can get in a lot of trouble
for it if you're in those four states
what was it South Dakota Idaho Nebraska
one of and Kansas yeah those four just
don't have it is my advice I'm not a
lawyer or your mom but I think it would
be a good idea to just don't bring it to
those states it's still very much
illegal and if they wanted to do a
crackdown not necessarily for marijuana
like if they wanted to get me for
instance for telling you these things
this is a way that they could lock you
up legally for resistance and you'd be
breaking the law they could do it so
there's a lot of reasons to try and get
this federally federally done and we
don't need to wait for this one we
really don't in fact the Republicans
might like to say that we legalized weed
for the the 2018 election that it
actually could help them and and yeah so
what I'm saying is there's hope and you
should write to your congressmen and
Senators right now there's no reason to
delay today's program is sponsored in
part by foo tour the tour is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your
or web browser you'll see a whole range
of forecasts covering topics across the
board politics sports so much more you
wager on predictions about real world
events using food tours in-game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account by
clicking the link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube and this
week on futur I posed the question will
robert molars trump russia investigation
end during this year during 2018 what do
you think place your bets and you can
sign up now at fruit or calm and start
making your forecasts on political
topics and so many other topics it's
free and it's available on both Android
and iOS as well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm